because
men and women are different and because
a man has to become something in order
to sleep around
he you're not gonna you're not gonna
okay you're not gonna sleep around with
like an overweight bomb
right you if we got overweight bum comes
up to you you going on a date with him
I don't know it depends on the
confidence
well okay but but if we look at the data
the results speak for themselves one out
of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year so we
don't owe them sex or understanding for
not being able to get laid just and
that's the same way like men don't owe
us relationships if we've slept around
it makes me laugh as well because if an
ugly person comes up to you in a club
and gives you a compliment or say
something nice it comes across as creepy
yeah right that guy is a creep if a
handsome person or a good looking person
comes up to you you're flirting like shy
and stuff like that you know so it it
depends on the person who sees it it's
really I think that's right also the
equivalent to men sleeping around not
being feds men saying oh like if I'm
broke should you still date me
so like women go for guys that are
established financially or that that's
what they want even if they're looking
potential wise they won't date a good
looking bomb for too long it won't be
long term okay so what
I'm saying you can't turn a home into a
housewife
hoes are Housewives right now
I actually agree with you to some level
like those girls do usually still get
married the problem is they leave they
get bored and statistically the data
supports that because a woman that's had
sex with more with that's a virgin when
she gets married has an 80 chance of a
happy marriage and if she has sex with
more than five people which most men
pray for nowadays it goes down to it
goes down to like 25 is that a happy
marriage or is that settling we don't
what do you what do you mean like that
the woman that was a virgin and then
married like well you don't know how
good her sex life is well you ask her if
she's happy in her marriage and there's
80 chance after 10 years she says yes
I'm happy where the girl that's had sex
with more than five people there's a 25
chance that she says yes I'm happy so if
I'm a dude and I'm thinking Hmm do I
want to grow with more bodies or less
bodies I'd pick less bodies but that's
because oh she knows isn't it like
that's that's also the only person so
that's what she's going to be happy with
if you've tried and tested around and
obviously you know you're right that's
correct like the more you have to
compare it to but it's like
guys don't want to be compared to a
whole bunch of dudes that's not
attractive
what's wrong with
with being satisfied I mean
you know you're saying oh well I'm gonna
go and test drive a whole load of cars
before we decide which one you want to
spend the rest of your life with But
there again if somebody somebody just
gave you a car you'd be happy with it
and and and isn't that in at the end of
the day isn't that the objective to be
happy yeah yeah so yeah but everyone if
you know there was a there was an old
song in the 60s if you can't be with the
one you love be the Love the One You're
With yeah people have it people have
this no it's not it's not certainly the
thing is the only reason why you think
it's happening is because Disney is yeah
Disney who's convinced you that you're
somehow or another you're you're you
know you're a princess that that
deserves to have a prince and the
numbers of princes are very very low
well and the issue is you have girls
that are fours fives and sixes sleeping
with eight nines and tens and they think
they're on that level and so when they
actually meet the guy that's gonna marry
them and is at their level that'll put a
ring on it they think they're settling
but they're not settling your levels
what you can get yeah so they're dating
up then there's their women's sleep up
yeah because and you can and you we have
more data on this than ever because we
have dating app data which is extremely
honest so it says what what do women
want and it's between five to fifteen
percent of guys they're screwing all the
girls I mean I went to um a pickup
artist boot camp which is I I did this
for a YouTube video where it's like
basically a camp where these guys teach
other guys how to get laid and they'll
teach them things like for example a
girl's not going to want to sleep with
you if you haven't touched her the whole
date and that's something you wouldn't
really think about as a woman like you
know they touch your arm touch your back
that like builds attraction and
um like one of the dudes that was um
like teaching the camp I literally saw
him take home four girls in four days
and none of those girls were that cute
but it's like those guys are literally
sleeping with everybody I'm surprised
because I would have said if you have to
go to a pickup class to get girls he was
the instructor
if you want to make a dollar oh my it
was like oh my God they they spent a lot
of money on that camp so if any if you
ever want a business I pick up I'm just
interested well there were so many girls
at a men's pickup no it was just me it
wasn't a lot of girls it was Oh you mean
no it was it was basically like they
would okay all these guys would fly to
Vegas and then at Vegas they would teach
them how to get laid at like the clubs
and stuff so I did it as like a vlog
this is like I don't know you probably
find it on my channel like six months to
a year ago
um yeah and I just wanted to see like
it's kind of like nosy like what are the
guys talking about
the same question is like because we
live in a really hypersexualized culture
like
I know like I talked to my girlfriends
and stuff and they blatantly lie about
how many guys they've had sex with but a
lot of guys don't want virgins either so
it's like it's kind of a no-win
situation yeah I mean I think virgins
have a hard time too because the guys
that are sleeping with everybody like
they don't want to wait either yeah yeah
um but on the other end you know what's
weird I've actually asked guys a lot
about this they they say like 10 is the
number that's too high but they'd like
prefer someone around like five like
three to five seems to be like the magic
yeah but then they just lie about it
yeah but that's the thing like I I don't
think
it hurts the women themselves because
it's in their head they're the ones that
are going to be comparing that's why I
say like like hoes get wifed I think
every girl in this room like we can all
think of a hoe that her boyfriend has no
idea what she used to do right yeah yeah
and and the problem is they leave
yeah I don't I don't have a solution for
you I wish I wish I could it does hurt
women a lot when they sleep around
though yeah because then they can't
really Bond yeah yeah it's very
difficult to do that unless it's like
the most desired guy it's like in the
one percent of guys yeah no that's
that's the problem with it is um
yeah it's like the it's the more guys
you sleep with the more you have to
compare it to and the more like the one
you end up with isn't gonna measure up
sorry someone was gonna say something
yeah but it's more than just that I
would say you know this whole package
elaborate
it's the whole package it's not just you
know how good they are in bed
for who for the woman
because you're saying that she'll get
bored and then obviously leave if
because she slept around and had other
men but I'm saying it's more it's more
than just you know just sleeping
together you're right I mean women
compare in more than one way but I don't
think that makes it better if anything
that makes it worse
because you'll think oh that guy had
money that guy had muscles
I guess then that's when you're set a
little bit like oh gosh all right he
don't have the muscle workouts I mean
imagine if men said oh she's not a
Victoria's Secret model
so I'm settling
oh her stomach isn't like perfect yeah
but most guys are like if she's hot
enough nice enough I'll take her
God you know so well
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats real
quick
um okay guys also um like the video the
like is the most important metric that
you can do to help YouTube push out
these videos in the algorithm while
you're at it subscribe to the channel
I'm so tired I'm so tired of y'all
watching these videos and not
subscribing I know some of you will
giving me heat in the chat because I put
it on subscribers only but a subscribe
is free okay it is free subscribe to the
channel
um also
okay so drazian gaming the average man
can physically harm you anytime he wants
why would I be intimidated when I'm told
to hold back by Society what are you on
Billy boy I was a virgin when I got
married by choice my wife was not it has
made her relationship very difficult it
has been eight years my wife has since
told her sister to stay a Virgin mgtow
by Logic panel just be honest please the
homeless population is like 90 percent
male because women can find someone to
pay their bills stop lying women don't
date bums it's fine just don't lie about
it
um Eli for isha's hat collection which
is wait for it's just hat collection
when some is blue in oh you're getting a
hat collection yeah I was thought in the
hat collection you will see it on the
channel every time I'm on different hats
yeah donate to that guys make sure you
see protecting for IT Help me the the UK
Economist great new studio pro thank you
everyone clap yeah hey new studio
um please ask if they're open if I'm
going to ask this after the break okay
um Chris girl in the yellow oh this is a
hundred dollar Super Chat
let's go girl girl in the yellow I'm 38
and I make 100K a month you don't
intimidate me or my colleagues saying
that men are intimidated by you is how
you cope with the fact that high net
worth men don't want you for a serious
relationship learn to be more
self-related where you sound delusional
um Sydney Jacob hello from New Zealand
love the show I introduced it to my ex
to help her become more feminine love
you Pearl the benevolent benevolent
Patriot patriarch
um these ladies level of cap is over
nine thousand beans no man would date a
woman like a feminist but you can say
you don't need a man but to become more
valuable you need to be appreciated but
the way you're acting you're just
depreciating 90 free Tope please ask
when do women love men as they are mgtow
by Logic men also date on potential
which is also never delivered and when
it's almost always revoked
um 90 free top pay get new skin toner
face looks green green pants Alistar
Horton wow the woman's ego in the video
is more inflated than the American
economy
um
mgtow by Logic women Define settling as
anything below Perfection which is just
stupid but ruin your life if you want I
don't care my life is great Jaya Uncle
Barry speaks like my dad but if he was
white I love how respectful the young
guests are quiet and respectful when the
Elder Statesman speaks stoic masculinity
will women settle more they settle for
being one of many instead of being the
one 90 free Tope ninja you might not
know it but there's a Ninja on set
Daniel a is it really settling when it's
what you can get surely you are on the
same level when it comes to Value
Lazarus how did y'all get
cakesha on this show Asian fresh great
setup Pearl JC can you ask Moon Knight
when season two comes out mgtow by Logic
if women settled divorce would nearly be
nearly non-existent men settle way more
it's so lopsided it's actually a trick
question stoic masculinity women don't
settle they just date outside of their
league and then wind up with men on
their level people Desmond they are
delusional men settle more we're simple
zetek News Network Pearl rocks and has
my respect for leaving her corporate
life to raise awareness on these key
um psychosocial subject matters
Playboy on Lotte Pearl got that new
studio congrats speak the gospel for Men
Let the 304s understand their actions
and reactions men don't wipe Hoes mgtow
by Logic the average average Modern
Woman is fatter lazier and less feminine
than they have ever been in all of human
history men are the ones settling not
women hypergamy requires it it's math
Alexander Way Boss Hogg says big up on
the west gate massive Rob Burns Pearl
fresh and fitter coming to the UK
they're looking for an embassy it should
be you considering
Alistar Horton how are you settling into
the new place silly sausage it is harder
to be a sperm donor than it is to get
into Harvard height requirement of five
eight or five ten lesbians who don't
need men still won't select 80 percent
of men sperm sperm bank won't even make
donations if you are short as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible